in my previous video on subsets and
supersets I stated that to show quality
you have to prove that each side of an
equation are subsets of each other so to
prove the distributive law we're gonna
have this video we're gonna have the
next video in this video I'm gonna be
showing that a is a a intersection B u C
is a subset of a intersection B Union a
intersection C so let's start the proof
suppose that X is an element of a
intersection B you see then X is an
element of a and X is an element of B
Union C by definition of the
intersection so we still know that X is
an element of a and by definition we
know that X is an element of B or X is
an element of C from this we can deduce
that X is an X is an element of a and X
is an element of B or X is an element of
a and X is an element of C now by
definition we can put this or rewrite
this as X as an element of a
intersection B or X is an element of a
intersection C and finally we can deduce
that X is an element of a intersection B
Union a intersection C so there you have
it we've shown that since X is an
element of a intersection B Union C and
X is an element of a intersection B
Union a intersection C X is in both of
these and therefore a intersection B
Union C is in fact a subset of a
intersection B Union a intersection C